these people
are challenging themselves to stay
underwater for
as long as possible some go for
half a day while others managed to spend
an entire week fully submerged
what would happen to your body if you
tried this challenge
would your skin fall off on today's
challenge
we're going to find out this
is your body on 24 hours
underwater in 2006
david blaine challenged himself to be
underwater
for a full seven days he trained with
the navy seals to lose
23 kilograms so his body would require
less oxygen
but we're dropping you into this
challenge
right away with no training at all
is this something you'll be able to
handle
the moment you go underwater you'd use
less oxygen and
therefore could stay submerged longer
as your heart slowed down your blood
would be
diverted to essential organs that need
oxygen the most
like your brain heart and kidneys
this shunting is called peripheral
vasoconstriction
okay you're 30 seconds in at this point
you would want to breathe again you
could
keep holding your breath for two minutes
if you're
trained for underwater emergencies but
past
that time you'll need to be assisted by
a breathing device
if you're a free diver you'd be able to
keep going for more than 10 minutes
to do so you would have expelled carbon
dioxide
out of your lungs by hyperventilating
okay now that your body is saturated
with oxygen
you'd want to avoid any activity in
order to slow down your heart rate
just stay still as much as possible
after a five minute exposure to water
your skin would prune
especially your fingers and toes these
aquatic wrinkles happen
because of the narrowing of blood
vessels in your skin
this shrinking is called digital
vasoconstriction
but this is nothing you haven't
experienced before let's keep going
if you spent these past 20 minutes
without any breathing device
there's a high chance you'd experience
brain damage
the steady build up of carbon dioxide in
your blood would
turn it into an acidic brew muscle
spasms and
disorientation could follow as well as a
racing heart
and ultimately death so
to avoid all that you'll need a scuba
tank if you have
any hope of finishing this challenge
okay now that you have some pure oxygen
you think this challenge will be easier
right well i'm not that sure
after seven hours of soaking you could
suffer from hypothermia
if the water temperature drops below
21.1 degrees celsius
your body temperature would dip down to
35 degrees celsius
or lower you'd start to shiver and your
pulse would be weak
the cold would affect your organs
especially your heart
and nervous system you could eventually
go unconscious with no warm-up
hypothermia can lead to your entire
respiratory system
shutting down and your death
so for your survival the water
temperature should be kept around
26.7 degrees
okay after 24 hours of underwater life
you'll notice some bubbles forming on
your skin
these are known as vesicles they develop
because water becomes trapped between
your outer
and middle layers of skin they will
continue to form the longer you stay in
the water
and eventually burst
and now as you finally finish this
challenge and get out of the water
your skin would start to peel away from
the popped vesicles
you'd need medical attention immediately
as you'd likely have a severe headache
along with other health issues
[Music]
okay sure you managed to make it out of
this challenge alive but
it definitely wouldn't be worth it if
you want to relax
i've heard that withstanding the cold
can
enhance your well-being want to give it
a try
okay we'll see what that challenge
brings on another episode
of your body on